[Musique]
des mafias de l'est originaire de l'ex
empire soviétique
voli braconniers
[Musique]
et
à travers les tatouages ils peuvent
reconstituer plus ou moins le parcours
criminel de l'individu le nombre
d'années de prison si cet individu a tué
une pâture
[Musique]
des tatouages sur les épaules signifie
qu'ils ne porteront jamais d'uniformes
les tatouages sur les genoux signifie
qu'ils n'oublieront jamais devant
l'autorité
[Musique]
bon
aujourd'hui ils jouent à domicile c'est
à dire qu'ils sont installés ici les
équipes aussi
à
[Musique]
on
plus on arrête de l'équipe géorgienne
plus il en arrive enfin bon on a
l'impression que là c'est un puits sans
fond et ça fait maintenant elle a
quelques années qu'ils ont quadrillé la
france et puis qu'ils activent dans
l'ombre ces équipes de cambrioleurs
[Musique]